This is part
three of the FOM
lecture on head and
neck embryology.
In this last section,
we're going to be
talking about germ
layer contributions
to various head and
neck structures.
So there are three
major germ layers in the
body. So these are
ectoderm, mesoderm, and
endoderm, same as other
parts of the body.
And in the ectoderm, in
addition to
the epidermis,
the ectoderm leads
to the creation of
the brain and the
cranial nerves. And
these are because
it is derived from
this neural tube, which
is going to become
both the brain and
the spinal cord.
You also have placodes
that are derived from
ectoderm, as we talked
about in the previous
part of the lecture.
And these are
associated with some of
the special senses in
the head and neck,
including the eye lens,
vestidial and
cochlea in the
inner ear and
nasal cavity.
And ectoderm is
also responsible
for generating
parotid gland.
Moving on to the
mesoderm, as expected,
these form the bones and
cartilaginous tissues,
arteries, and muscles.
And in the head,
a lot of these are
coming from pharyngeal
structures. Remember
the pharyngeal arches.
And the funny thing
about in the head is
that these mesodermal
tissues will interact
with what's called
neocrest cells, which
we'll be talking
about in the next
section. But neocrest
cells are ectodermally
derived, a very special
set of cells that
can kind of go from
ectoderm into cell
populations that kind
of act like mesoderm.
And then you also have
the skull, which is
part of the bone and
cartilaginous tissues
in the head. So
that's derived from
mesoderm as well. And
then endoderm, you have
the glandular tissues,
except for the
parotid gland, and then
the mucosae around the
oral and the nasal
cavities and beyond.
so i promise that
i'll be talking about
neurocrest cells so
neurocrest cells are
populations of cells
that originate in
the neural fold so
recall in earlier
embryonic lectures
that you have an
ectodermal layer in very
early embryonic stage
and the ectodermal
layer is going to
invaginate and then
is going to split off
and that split off part
is going to form a tube
and called neurotube
and this is what's
going to become the
brain and the spinal cord
and what you're
also left with
is this continuous
ectodermal
layer which is
going to later
produce the epidermis
but then during this
invagination process
there's a region
that's folded. And
this is called a neural
fold. And from there
emerges these very
special populations
of multi-potent cells
called neurocrest
cells. And neurocrest
cells are, again,
ectodermally derived,
but forms secondary
mesenchyme. So these
are mesoderm-like
structures. They act
like although they
came out of ectoderm.
And these neurocrest
cells migrate all
over the body to
turn into a wonderful
array of different
tissues. So these
include cartilage
and bone, teeth,
skin, melanocytes,
smooth muscles,
glands, adipose
tissue, neurons, glia,
adrenal medulla,
et cetera. And it's
responsible for most
of the connective and
the skeletal tissue
of the head, nerves,
and pigment cells.
And here are the
derivatives of the
neurocrest cells in
the head and neck
in all its glory.
So in terms of
cartilage and bone,
it forms most of
the bones and
cartilage in the head.
So these include
the facial bones,
which are listed
here, as well
as some in the
cranial base,
including parts of
the sphenoid bone.
And it also forms
all three of
the middle your
ossicles, the
malleus, incus,
and stapes,
hyoid, and the
laryngeal cartilage.
So these are all
cartilage and bony
structures that
are derived from
pharyngeal arches
from part one of this
lecture on head and
neck embryology.
In the same way, for
the nervous system
derivatives, it includes
sensory ganglia of
cranial nerve 5, 7,
9, and 10, which are
branchiomeric nerves. So
these are cranial nerves
that are associated
with pharyngeal arches.
And it also includes
their peripheral nerves.
And for the muscles,
so the neocrest cells
do not directly become
muscles, but they
interact with the
mesoderms in the
pharyngeal arches to
form the muscles of the
head and neck, including
the jaw muscles.
And then there
are other key
structures that
come from neocrest
cells. So these
include teeth,
particularly the dentine
component of it,
but not enamel.
It also forms dermis
and hyperdermis of the
face and the neck,
creates the choroid and
sclera of the eye,
and melanocytes in the
iris, as well as the
rest of the body. So if
you think that someone's
eyes and their eye
color is beautiful, you
can thank neurocrest
cells. And it's also
responsible for developing
meninges and connective
tissues of lacrimal
salivary and thymus
clads not the glandular
tissues themselves
but the connective
tissues surrounding
them and now what's
interesting is so neurocrest
cells have all these
different kinds of
derivatives so there have
been a lot of research
on why we have so
many dog breeds and one
of the secrets could
be related to neurocrest
cells and that's
been demonstrated for
some of the attributes.
So for example, if you
look across different
dog breeds, you definitely
see quite different
and varying skull
shapes. For example,
looking at husky skill
and chihuahua skull.
And then obviously
dog breeds are
known for the
differences in fur color.
And what is the cause
or what are responsible
for some of these
traits? Well, it all
goes back to neurocrest
cells. So there
must've been
artificial selection on
neurocrest cells that
produced all these
coordinated changes very
quickly historically.
Now, we're going
to end it talking
about clinical
correlates related to
neurocrest cells.
And so one of them
is called Treacher
-Collins syndrome,
and it's caused by
genetic disorder that
involves faulty
migration of neurocrest
cells in the head
in the pharyngeal
arches one and two
and occurs about one
in 50,000 births.
And so the symptoms
or the syndrome
includes hearing loss,
downturned eyes,
underdevelopment
of the midface,
micronathia or a small
lower jaw and cleft
palate. So these
are all coordinated
traits that neurocrest
cell controls, especially
the development of
the facial bones.
So Treacher-Collin
syndrome is the result
of faulty migration
of neurocrest cells.
So let's end it with
an example question.
So a six-year-old
girl exhibits a
swelling in the anterior
part of her neck,
just inferior to the
thyroid bone. Which
of the following may
explain a swelling?
So in this question,
think about
the location of
the opening. Is
it on the midline
of the neck or
the lateral aspect
of the neck? So
the answer is C, which
is associated with the
thyroglossal duct cyst.
So if the swelling
or opening was
associated with the
lateral part of the
neck, then it would
have been the intact
cervical sinus.
And the obliteration
of the cervical
sinus, which is answer
B, which this is just
part of normal
development. So this
would not lead to any
particular swelling.
And then obliteration
of thytoglossal
ducts, similarly is
what happens under
typical development.
And then incomplete
closure of
secondary palate is
something that would
cause cleft palate.
So a totally different
kind of condition.
So together with the
previous lecture on
introduction to the
head and neck, I hope
I've convinced you
that the head and
the neck that supports
it is a truly special
and wonderfully
complex region. I know
it's a difficult
and very complicated
area of the body,
but I also hope that
you enjoy and appreciate
this complexity.
So just to finish
up this lecture,
These are the
topics that I
recommend you
focusing on in
your preparation
for the exams.
So first, make
sure you know the
derivatives of the
pharyngeal arches, pouches,
clefts, and
membranes. So complete
that table and study
off of that table.
Development of the
face, skull, palate,
tongue, thyroid
gland, placos,
and the pituitary
gland. Make sure you
understand the
process involved in
the development of
these structures.
And then the germ layer
and the neurocrestal
origins of the head
and neck structures.
And then, of
course, the clinical
implications
that arise from
abnormalities in head
and neck development
that I covered
in the lectures.
This is the end
of the FOM lecture
on the head and
neck embryology.
And I'd be grateful
if you can provide
any feedback on my
lectures, which you
can do by clicking
in the hyperlink in
the PowerPoint files.
And if you have
any questions about
the lecture content,
please do not
hesitate to email me.
The email address
is down here.
Thank you for
listening and
hope you have a
wonderful day.